and now we are all set for
the start of game two blue jays trying
to make it five in a row
as they've won their last four games
including the sweep of the orioles in
baltimore they're at 500.
well here you go here's this opportunity
right now first inning base has loaded
nobody out
3-2 pitch is popped up shallow in left
field here comes guerrielle and he can't
get there in time
that's it on a bounce mccutchen is in to
score
everybody moving up hoskins going to
third harper at second
on the battle that's finally won by dd
gregorius
and for the second consecutive game
philly with a one-nothing start yeah
trent's thrown
19 pitches and hasn't gotten it out yet
as you see waggis back
up early in this ball game still nobody
out the 01.
swinging a line drive into right field
down for a base hit
hoskins is in to score harper gets the
stop sign at third
grigorius up to second and rbi base it
by alex baum
two nothing philly still nobody out and
here's neil walker
that one's lined out to center field
miss red initially gretchick makes the
catch
tagging from third is harper the throw
to the plate is cut off it's a sacrifice
fly
and it's three-nothing phillies here is
andrew knapp
the switch-hitting back-up catcher for
the phillies
the pitch to nap that's in the air to
left field
backing up guriel he's still on the run
getting to the warning track reaches out
and he can't make the play the ball hops
on the warning track skips over the wall
that's an automatic double gregorius is
in to score
ball moves up on the double by nap
four nothing philadelphia about andrew
mccutchen coming to the plate for the
second time in the game already and it's
still the top of the first inning
that one's hit down the right field line
going back on it is hernandez he get all
turned around it's over his head
at a one hop off the base of the wall
this may clear the bases mccutchen pulls
in
for an extra base hit its second base it
does clear them the fills have busted it
open
here in the top of the first inning hey
andrew how'd you do in the first well
it's two for two with three rbis
is that good this will be his fourth
game of the season
he hasn't pitched very well so far this
season his whip is almost
two marks per innings and hit
sprinting's pitch there's two down and
that'll get to oscar hernandez to the
plate
hernandez with a fly ball that he hits
pretty well to deep left field and it's
gone
say oscar hernandez goes deep and the
blue jays get a couple on the board in
the bottom of the first
well that's really important to answer
back
cut into that lead and you know what as
a pitcher you get seven runs in the top
half of the inning you want to put up a
zero in the bottom half of the inning
and he really didn't square this ball up
he hit it down
off the barrel a little bit down toward
the label but he's so
strong he hits it out of the ballpark
there's t oscar hernandez who hammered
his first time up
swinging into this third strikeout for
velasquez and there are two outs
nice little wrinkle there that spike on
that knuckle curve
nice rotation hernandez way out in front
2-2 pitch is hitting the air to center
field coming in to get it as kingery
he makes the catch and the blue jays go
one two
three they're through four in buffalo
scores the same as it was at the end of
the first philly's leading 72.
there's jay bruce next pitch swing
and a miss he got him and jay bruce goes
down on strikes for the second time
bottom fall out of this one see that
split grip
2-2 pitch strike 3 called missed away
but good enough for vic carapaza as we
get set to move into
well we are well into our number six
of baseball today in buffalo
phillies lead it seven to two we go to
the bottom of the fifth inning
brandon drury starts it off swing and a
miss
five strikeouts for velasquez who's
allowed one hit
since that first inning much better pace
for vince
the last outing he had here at home one
two pitch swing and a miss
challenge fastball by velasquez right
down the middle
and he blows it by grichik vince
velazquez strikes out the side in order
in the fifth
bottom of the sixth vince velasquez does
go back out to the mound
and he works to rowdy teles and he hits
it
a mile to right field oh
man over the tent and over the seats
out in right a monster home run for
rowdy teles
boy would he hit some there are a lot of
no doubters that one went
forever and here is guriel
guriel gets into one and sends it a long
way to left field and this is gonna go
all of a sudden it's a one-run ball game
curry won the game in game one with a
base hit to left field and he makes it
an interesting ball game now
jansen's the runner at third biggio's
hit second agrics at first
blue jay's trying to come all the way
back
and to the backstop jansen on his way
home
safe and they've tied it what a comeback
in an improbable
situation and teles hits one off the end
of the bat shallow center field it's
gonna drop
one run is home second run to the plate
and they've got a two run lead
unbelievable what a win this would be
the blue jays got
seven in the bottom of the six to take a
two-run lead it's down to one right now
and he got him aj cole strikes him out
and the blue jays come back from a seven
to nothing first inning deficit
to win the game and sweep the
doubleheader